[Musik]
neuer gigant der autobranche fiat
chrysler und peugeot wollen fusionieren
und viertgrößter autobauer der welt
werden
klima klage gescheitert
bauern wollten die bundesregierung
gerichtlich zu mehr ehrgeiz beim
klimaschutz zwingen wieder schwerer fall
von kindesmissbrauch ermittler in nrw
gehen von mindestens sechs opfern aus
das jüngste soll noch nicht mal ein jahr
alt sein
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten am
reformationstag für den sport ist
norbert lehmann an meiner seite wunder
von mir
die mega fusion in der kriselnden
autobranche ist beschlossene sache
die gespräche zwischen fiat chrysler und
dem französischen peugeot konzern zu dem
auch opel gehört verliefen erfolgreich
damit entstünde der viertgrößte
autobauer der welt größer sind da nur
noch volkswagen toyota und renault
nissan
es soll eine fusion unter gleichen sein
also wollen beide partner jeweils die
hälfte des neuen gemeinsamen konzerns
halten und zusammen 8,7 millionen autos
pro jahr verkaufen
die zentrale des neuen riesen soll in
den niederlanden stehen
volker check berichtet die karten neu
gemischt mit mehr als einem dutzend
traditionsmarken könnte der neue konzern
am weltmarkt bucher mit dabei modelle
aus dem peugeot konzern aus der fiat
chrysler familie und auch die der
deutschen post tochter opel
experten sehen große
einsparmöglichkeiten vor allem bei
elektroautos neuer antriebe insbesondere
batterieelektrische fahrzeuge dürften
eine wesentliche rolle spielen man
könnte beispielsweise eine plattform
schaffen auf der man dann eben
verschiedene modelle der einzelnen
marken angefangen geben von peugeot oder
fiat bis hin zu opel
man könnte eben solche fahrzeuge darauf
aufsetzen opel gehört seit gut zwei
jahren zum peugeot konzern und wird mit
harter hand auf effizienz und gewinne
getrimmt die gerüchte um die neue fusion
führen bei opelaner sorgen
vielen ist noch der zickzackkurs unter
dem vorbesitzer general motors in
erinnerung
die ig metall hält entlassungen für
unrealistisch es gebe schließlich
verträge mit dem neuen besitzer
dass diese nachricht natürlich zunächst
einmal ängste und sorgen auslöst das
liegt auf der hand aber gerade vor dem
hintergrund ist die bedeutung des
zukunfts tarifvertrages außerordentlich
hoch er bietet den mitgliedern der ig
metall schutz vor betriebsbedingten
kündigungen bis zum 31 juni 2023 denke
opel wird in den nächsten ein bis zwei
jahren etwas mehr in ruhe gelassen
werden büro wird sich sehr viel mehr auf
ihr chrysler kümmern müssen dass sie
beim peugeot konzern sanieren können das
haben sie bewiesen denn opel schreibt
erstmals seit 20 jahren wieder schwarze
zahlen
der werksschließungen sind nicht geplant
aber die opelaner sind doch in sorge wie
wir gerade hörten frank bethmann an der
frankfurter börse wie schätzen sie denn
die chancen dieser fusion ein
na da könnte tatsächlich etwas
zusammenwachsen was auch zusammenpasst
psa der opel-mutterkonzern wieder
erstarkt in europa fiat chrysler zwar
schon lange nicht mehr in der ersten
automobilen liga aber sehr gut
aufgestellt in nordamerika man würde
sich also ganz gut ergänzen deswegen
heute auch überwiegend positive
reaktionen wie die der französischen
wirtschafts und finanzministers umfasst
wir erleben einen zusammenschluss in der
automobilindustrie der spektakulär ist
es geht um die gemeinsame entwicklung
des autonomen fahrens und das
elektroauto ja mittendrin opel
einerseits die jetzt viel bessere chance
auf einen neuen wichtigen absatzmarkt
autos verkaufen zu können in den usa
andererseits die sorge dass die bisher
harte sanierung noch härter werden
könnte auch wenn das heute so niemand
sagte ausgeschlossen ist es nicht
danke ihnen von bethmann frankfurter
börse ein überblick über bisherige
fusion in der automobilbranche und eine
ausführliche analyse des neuesten
zusammenschlusses finden sie online auf
heute.de und jetzt zu einer besonderen
gerichtsverhandlung auf der anklagebank
die klimapolitik drei familien alle bio
bauern wollten die bundesregierung zu
mehr klimaschutz zwingen unterstützt von
greenpeace mit ihrer klage vor dem
berliner verwaltungsgericht sind sie
allerdings erst einmal gescheitert sei
attacke berichtet
die nordseeinsel pellworm im schnitt
liegt sie etwa ein meter unter dem
meeresspiegel
die landwirtin silke wachsen lebt seit
mehr als 20 jahren hier sturmfluten
kennt sie aber es hat sich was verändert
die sommerhochwasser werden einfach mehr
also das heißt es im sommer eben das
vorland unter wasser steht und dann auch
die nester und die eier die gelege
verschwinden und überspült werden
im vergangenen jahr hatte greenpeace sie
angesprochen und schnell war physik
gewachsen klar sie will die
bundesregierung auf einhaltung der
klimaziele mit verklagen
denn die bundesregierung hatte 2007
ehrgeizige klimaziele versprochen
deutschlands oberste ziel bis 2020 40
prozent der co2 emissionen einzusparen
dieses ziel aber wird weit verfehlt das
ist heute klar und genau deshalb sind
sie hier umweltaktivisten verklagen
seite an seite mit drei bio landwirten
unter insel gewachsen die
bundesregierung auf einhaltung der
klimaziele allerdings ohne erfolg
wir sind natürlich enttäuscht dass klar
wir haben alle mehr erhofft und mehr
gewünscht das ist klar aber wir gehen
mit dem guten gefühl raus wir haben viel
erreicht denn die richter zeigten der
verhandlung viel verständnis für das
anliegen der kläger die bundesregierung
soll verpflichtet werden auch
einzuhalten was sie verspricht eine
klare forderung der umweltschützer
nur kann ein politisches ziel ein
politisches vorhaben vor keinem gericht
eingeklagt werden
rechtlich gesehen war die klage der
umweltschützer daher von anfang an
chancenlos
sie hat ihn allerdings viel
aufmerksamkeit gebracht die
umweltschützer haben das gericht
geschickt als bühne genutzt
in die usa da arbeiten die
oppositionellen demokraten am
impeachment also dem
amtsenthebungsverfahren gegen präsident
trump der vorwurf amtsmissbrauch
es geht um die sogenannte ukraine affäre
die versuche des präsidenten die ukraine
zu ermittlungen zu drängen die seinem
rivalen joe biden schaden könnten
immer mehr ehemalige und aktuelle
mitarbeiter trumps müssen im kongress
aussagen aus washington berichtet mrt
wissen
das ergebnis ist eindeutig mit 232 zu
196 stimmen liegt die demokratische
mehrheit fest dass von nun an die
zeugenaussagen öffentlich stattfinden
mit weitgehenden frage rechten sogar für
die anwälte des präsidenten gestritten
hatten die abgeordneten vorher entlang
der parteilinien ist unsere pflicht und
niemand steht über dem gesetz
die demokraten setzten ihre kampagne
fort die legitimität des präsidenten zu
untergraben sogar aus dem weißen haus
wie oberstleutnant alexander windmann
belasten donald schon schwer
windmann 1 im irak verwundet und
hochdekorierter veteran war anwesend
beim telefonat zwischen trump und dem
ukrainischen präsidenten selensky er
berichtet von auslassungen in der
mitschrift und von seiner beschwerde an
die rechtsabteilung dass der präsident
eine fremde regierung aufforderte gegen
einen us-bürger joe biden zu ermitteln
windmann ist amerikaner aber weil er
einst in der ukraine geboren wurde
beschimpfen trump anhänger den
kriegshelden als möglichen sprung um
cordes final donald trumps heute
verbreiten das verfahren sei ein versuch
den präsidenten zu zerstören die
demokraten wollen nun die öffentlichkeit
überzeugen dass donald trump seines
amtes enthoben werden muss bleibt der
präsident bei seiner verteidigungslinie
es gibt nichts zu beanstanden und
wiederholen die zeugen das was sie schon
vorher ausgesagt haben noch einmal unter
eid vor laufenden kameras dann wird eine
mehrheit im repräsentantenhaus für eine
amtsenthebung stimmen
danach würde im senat ein richtiger
prozess stattfinden aber nur wenn er am
ende mindestens 20 republikaner mit den
demokraten stimmen würde trump aus dem
amt entfernt nach nordrhein-westfalen zu
einem furchtbaren kriminalfall wieder
sind mindestens sechs kinder zu opfern
von kinderschändern geworden
vier verdächtige wurden festgenommen sie
sollen ihre eigenen kinder und
stiefkinder sexuell missbraucht die
taten gefilmt und weiterverbreitet haben
die polizei stellte riesige datenmengen
sicher thomas münten berichtet zunächst
soll die polizei in bergisch gladbach
nur einen tatverdächtigen festnehmen
er soll sein eigenes kind missbraucht
haben bei der hausdurchsuchung stellen
die beamten dann jedoch drei terabyte
daten mit kinderpornografischem inhalt
sicher das klingt wenig ist aber wenn
man das in bilddateien oder in word
dateien ausdrucken sind das regalwände
da sind hunderttausende von bildern und
schätzt die nie auswerten müssen eine
20-köpfige sonderkommission wird
eingesetzt obwohl bisher nur wenige
prozent der daten ausgewertet sind
ergeben sich sofort weitere
verdachtsmomente für die ermittler
man hat dann priorisiert indem man
zunächst mal mobiltelefone ausgewertet
hat und hat dann relativ zeitnah
festgestellt dass es also kontakt zu
anderen personen mit denen bilder
getauscht worden sein sollen
beziehungsweise auch missbräuche
stattgefunden haben sollen und die
polizei hat dann diese verfahren an
andere staatsanwaltschaften in nordrhein
westfalen aber auch in hessen abgegeben
mit dem resultat dass auch dort
haftbefehle beantragt und auch
vollstreckt worden sind bisher sind
sechs opfer identifiziert zwischen unter
einem jahr und zehn jahren halt
missbraucht von ihren vätern oder
stiefväter die polizei versucht mit
allen mitteln festzustellen ob ein
kriminelles netzwerk hinter den tätern
steckt wir wissen das nicht aber genau
darum geht es wir wollen natürlich
feststellen ob es einen gefahren
überhang gibt wie wir das nennen also
gibt es hinweise darauf dass
möglicherweise weitere kinder opfer
geworden sind oder derzeit noch opfer
werden
der mutmaßliche haupttäter kommt das
bergisch gladbach seine frau und sein
kind werden psychologisch betreut
wenige monate nach seiner abschiebung in
den libanon ist ein führendes mitglied
des bremer mehrere clans zurück in
deutschland
trotz einreise und aufenthaltsverbot
ibrahimi werde im libanon mit dem tod
bedroht sagte dessen anwalt deshalb habe
er für seinen mandanten asyl beantragt
miri war hier mehrfach verurteilt worden
wegen drogenhandels erpressung und
entführung aus bremen katharina
weisgerber ibrahim miri in begleitung
seines anwalts auf dem weg zur bank
außenstelle in bremen am mittwoch
aufnahmen von radio bremen wir werden
uns jetzt erstmal bei der security
anmelden und dann sehen dass wir
vorsprechen um den asylantrag zu stellen
im juli dieses jahres war das oberhaupt
des clans durch die behörden in den
libanon abgeschoben worden
nach auskunft seines anwalts reiste er
in den vergangenen tagen jedoch illegal
nach deutschland zurück immer wieder
geriet der libanese mit dem gesetz in
konflikt hier aufnahmen von 2018 wegen
erpressung drogendelikte nötigung für
die sicherheitsbehörden war der
46-jährige eine führungsfigur der
organisierten kriminalität auch weiter
als chef des seit 2011 in bremen
verbotenen rockerclubs mongols bekannt
laut innenbehörde besteht ein einreise
und aufenthaltsverbot führende innen
politiker fordern nun weitreichendere
grenzkontrollen in deutschland wir
müssen fälle wie diesen
wiederholungstäter menschen mit einer
wiedereinreise sperre dublin wiederholer
direkt auf der grenzlinie zurückweisen
können solange die schengen außengrenzen
nicht funktionieren und dass die im
moment nicht funktionieren sieht man an
diesem fall beim verlassen der bank
behörde wurde premiere gestern von der
polizei festgenommen und dem haftrichter
vorgeführt
nun sitzt der frühere clan-chef in
abschiebehaft protestanten in
deutschland haben heute den
reformationstag gefeiert
mit gottesdiensten wie hier in der
lutherstadt wittenberg erinnern sie an
das wirken martin luthers laut
überlieferung soll der augustinermönch
vor rund 500 jahren seine 95 thesen über
buße und applus an die tür der
schlosskirche zu wittenberg angeschlagen
haben dadurch leitete er die reformation
ein die schließlich zur abspaltung von
der katholischen kirche führte
jetzt zu einem klassiker der malerei
rembrandt um seine großen werke zu sehen
müsste man eigentlich nach amsterdam new
york stockholm oder prag reisen oder ab
morgen einfach nach köln denn das
dortige wallraf richartz museum hat sich
gerade jede menge rembrandts zusammen
geliehen
mit ehrgeizigen ziel der die ausstellung
sieht soll sich ein bild machen können
von rembrandt dem künstler dem menschen
und seiner zeit kerstin edinger es war
das leben das ihn interessierte das
leben das ich in gesichtern abzeichnet
rembrandt van rijn
der niederländische maler des barock
konnte wie kein anderer menschen
porträtieren ihr innenleben auf die
leinwand bringen
rembrandt ist der menschen maler
schlechthin hat immer das gefühl man
erfährt auch etwas über den menschen
über das aussehen hinaus was den
charakter angeht was die seele des
menschen angeht neben 63 werken von
rembrandt zeigt die kölner ausstellung
anlässlich seines 350 todestages auch
gemälde seiner zeitgenossen und schüler
chronologisch genau beleuchtet sie sein
leben
die werke kommen aus aller welt das
berühmte bild der gelehrte im
studierzimmer zum beispiel aus der
nationalgalerie in prag auch viele
selbstporträts zu sehen ob als gemälde
oder kunstvolle radierung rembrandt war
ein meister der selbstvermarktung im
amsterdam des 17ten jahrhunderts ein
star
bremsend war der maler der dieser
punkten kulturmetropole mit dem
globalisierten mit dem reichen auch
manchmal sicher hektischen leben einfach
am besten entsprach und die schöne story
die high society war gierig auf seine
bilder so erfolgreich war
so gut war er auch im geldausgeben 1669
starb er verarmt
doch seine meisterhaften bilder wirken
bis heute
sie bringen uns menschen nahe die vor
fast 400 jahren gelebt haben die kölner
schau zeigt dies eindrucksvoll
tja und eindrucksvoll war auch der
höchst spannenden fußballabend dabei
allerdings später mit dem 2 2 1 im sagen
wir mal so genannten pokal kracher
zwischen dortmund und gladbach aber so
richtige so echte kracher die gab es in
kaiserslautern und berlin
denn der pokal hat nicht nur seine
eigenen gesetze sondern schreibt auch
seine eigenen geschichten riesenpatzer
auf dem betzenberg im pokalspiel gegen
nürnberg und der läuft lauterns torwart
lerner grill in der 89 minute bei 2 2
1-führung ein komplett aussetzer stadt
sieg verlängerung also die torlos bleibt
aber auch eine weitere geschichte
schreibt nach verletzung von nürnbergs
torwart patric klandt muss zum
anschließenden elfmeterschießen
feldspieler in rico valentini ins tor
die franken hatten ihr
auswechselkontingent schon erschöpft
der etatmäßige außenverteidiger
valentini im tor im elfmeterschießen
letztlich chancenlos und so wird lennart
grill am ende doch noch zum gefeierten
matchwinner
hält den alles entscheidenden sechs
elfmeter erst mal gemerkt wie schnell du
einer von einer halben stunde vom
buhmann vom politiker zum erhält man
kann aber das war ein geiles gefühl
ähnlich gute gefühle hatten lange zeit
auch die fans von zweitligist dynamo
dresden bei ihrem gastspiel in berlin
30.000 dresdner sahen eine irre pokal
partie in der sich die härter erst in
der nachspielzeit der verlängerung durch
das tor zum 3 3 ins elfmeterschießen
retten konnte
matchwinner auch hier deshalb ein
torwart der berliner thomas kraft hält
zwei elfmeter und die hertha damit
weiter und vokalwerke
nach der pokalpleite des ersten fc köln
beim regionalligisten saarbrücken
vorgestern hat sportchef armin veh heute
mitgeteilt den fußball bundesligisten
zum saisonende zu verlassen
wer sein nachfolger wird das ist noch
offen
alexander zverev ist für das atp-finale
der welt besten acht im november in
london qualifiziert nachdem der
italiener bertini gestern abend bei den
masters in paris schon im achtelfinale
ausgeschieden war
es wäre hatte letztes jahr dieses elite
turnier gewonnen
bayern gegen real nicht nur im fußball
ein kracher auch im basketball und da
hat der deutschen meister gestern amt in
der euroleague das starensemble aus
madrid sensationell mit 95 zu 86
geschlagen
der erste sieg der münchner gegen real
überhaupt bester werfer der bayern war
greg monroe mit 18
das war schon danke und jetzt noch ein
paar eindrücke von dem fest an dem sich
hierzulande die geister scheiden
halloween eher skeptisch die älteren
wohlmeinend die jüngeren begeistert die
ganz junge dabei können unsere bilder
aus hannover als beleg gelten sich und
andere erschrecken macht spaß und tut
gut wenn auch vielleicht nicht den
zähnen und ob sich so wirklich böse
geister vertreiben lassen ist ja auch
nicht ganz klar
zum wetter im westen wird es anfangen zu
regnen im osten bleibt es zunächst noch
sonnig zu den einzelheiten gleich mehr
von gunther tiersch so viele von uns das
heute journal mit marietta slomka um
viertel vor zehn und wir sind morgen
abend wieder für sie da um sie danke für
ihr interesse und noch einen entspannten
abend
[Musik]
liebe zuschauer das wetter am wochenende
sieht ganz anders aus als auf diesem
bild von heute es wird windig es wird
regnerisch
wir haben ein hochdruckgebiet dass uns
das sonnige wetter gebracht hat aber das
zieht sich weiter nach osten zurück wird
schwächer dafür können die regengebiete
von westen und dann auch morgen schon
erreichen und sie bringen aus dem
südwesten hier tatsächlich auch etwas
mildere luft mit ja heute nacht wird
aber noch so richtig knackig kalt also
frostig zwischen 0 und -6 grad wird ist
nur am rhein und im südwesten bleibt es
frostfrei da wird es am frühen morgen
dann auch schon stärker bewölkt sein und
tagsüber haben dann dort auch die
höchsten temperaturen am oberrhein
immerhin bis zu 15 grad sonst sind es
meist wieder sechs bis zehn grad und der
vormittag ist zweigeteilt im westen
haben wir die dicken wolken ab und zu
fängt es an zu regnen hund zurück bis
hier in westerwald sauerland zum teil
aber in der osthälfte wird der vormittag
noch ganz freundlich mit viel
sonnenschein zum nachmittag hin ziehen
die wolken dann weiter erreichen die
mitte deutschland später auch den osten
es regnet immer wieder leicht dazu aber
es ist zunächst erstmal kein starker
regen der wind wird allerdings auch
wieder kräftiger weht aus dem südosten
dazu und die aussichten es wird dann
weiterhin mild der mildeste tag wird der
samstag es wird windig und regnerisch
und das setzt sich eigentlich am sonntag
und in der nächsten woche fort ich
wünschen noch einen schönen abend und
machen sie es gut